نذهب الى هذه الدراسه الاستقصائيه التي
اجرتها شركه ايسلندا للطيران على اكثر من
7000 مسافر كشفت عن اهتمام ملحوظ بحجوزات
رمزيت استكشاف بلدي ضعفي قبل المتابعه الى
الوجهه النهائيه 34% من المسافرين بغرض
الترفيه منفتحون على حج رحلات ترانزيت او
التوقف الطويل وجهات اخرى وهي زياده قدرها
70% عن 2019 50% من المسافرين من رجال
الاعمال ابدو رغبه في حج رحله ترانزيت
لضرب عصفورين بحجر واحد فمنها قضاء رحله
العمل ومن القيام ببعض الانشطه الترفيهيه
يظهر البحث ان ثلاثه 33% من المسافرين عبر
المحيط الاطلسي مهتمون بزياره ايسلندا على
وجه التحديد في رحلات الترانزيت لمشاهده
ظاهره الشقق القطبيه التي تشتهر به البلاد
دول عده تسهل دخول المسافرين العابرين الى
اراضيها قبل متابعه الرحله اخرها السعوديه
التي اعلنت منحه تاشيره ترانزيت مجانا
للمسافرين عبر المملكه لمده اقصاها ست
وتسعين ساعه
[موسيقى]